à saint valentin il y a le fameux parc
des amoureux le lieu de rendez vous
incontournable du 14 février
il ya aussi l'autre symbole du village
les célèbres amoureux de raymond peynet
et des dessins qui font se déplacer les
passionnés
c'est magnifique et j'y viens de chaque
je viens chaque année voir j'adore il a
un beau coup de crayon tout est fin et
puis surtout les petits poèmes qui vont
avec la semaine 19 ans
sa valeur des cartes postales avec des
mots tendres
les amoureux ont aussi été décliné en
timbres chaque année le village de saint
valentin choisi l'un de ses dessins pour
illustrer la fiche de sa fête
une tradition respectée depuis 1986 pour
longtemps depuis la rencontre du maire
de saint valentin avec raymond peynet
valencien superbe kiosques et il y avait
un musicien qui jouait du violon une
jeune fille qui le regardaient la v6 et
des personnages et c'est devenu amoureux
de pagnol un dessin imaginé en 1942 il
aurait inspiré les amoureux des bancs
publics d'un certain georges brassens
un thème universel créé par un artiste
lui aussi très amoureux il est très
amoureux de ma mère sont connus lui il
avait 14 ans elle en avait cinq de plus
ils ne se sont jamais quittés à part la
guerre et mon père n'a jamais vu
d'autres femmes que ma mère et c'est en
fait sa vie quand l'amour dure toujours
quand l'amour n'a pas d'âge
on voit là un joli symbole pour la
saint-valentin la fête du tout les
amours
[Musique]